[Music]
it's been a challenging 20 months for
our library members so today i'm very
excited to be able to share with you
the concept plans for the new library
and community spaces building
before we take you on a virtual tour
it's worth thinking about what a modern
library is
a modern library is for community spaces
not just places for books welcome
to our virtual tour of the new gore
library and james [ __ ] community
center
the james coming wing has served the
community well but society has changed
significantly since it was built in 1972
what you're about to see is a building
more than double the size of the former
gore library
that will be home to our collection of
over 35 000
books magazines and more as well as free
and bookable community spaces it is set
over two floors
and many of the design aspects are a
result of your ideas
things like large windows providing lots
of natural light
people spaces for studying free wi-fi
and lots of plugs for your devices
entering through the new generous
airlock doors you are greeted by a light
bright central foyer
providing easy access to all areas of
the library
bright colors attract little ones to the
north facing children's area
a transformation of what was the supper
room into a place for education and play
with access to a courtyard if required
an adjacent story time and craft area
can be transformed into a space for
community use
thanks to sliding glass doors returning
to the central foyer we look southward
lights color and warmth replace the
starkness of the hall
there's the popular bank of free
computers while teenagers get their own
space nearby
large full-length windows facing onto
arabic street create a perfect area to
relax and watch the world go by
or read a newspaper or magazine look
further and you'll see
another community space one that's
accessible from the library
as well as the community centre there's
also two cosy booths available
returning to the entrance for you past
the staff area and the new public
toilets complete with a spacious parent
room
it's time to explore the first floor
you'll find more of our collection
including a research room
there are two more multi-purpose
community spaces as well as two study
rooms on this floor
all with lots of natural light let's
turn our attention now to the james
[ __ ] community centre
the message people gave us was they
value their community spaces
our regular users told us they needed a
large flexible area
somewhere to store things in somewhere
that felt their own
and we believe the new james coming
community center delivers
the separate entrance means it's
available any time of the day
not just during library hours and is
entirely self-contained with toilets and
a kitchen
there's room for indoor bowls yoga
classes or a family gathering
and when opened out the center can
accommodate 125 people seated at tables
or 250 standing or we can create three
separate spaces
all with access from the entrance and
don't forget the additional community
room
accessible from the library as well as
the center
and that brings out also an end thank
you for joining us
we look forward to your feedback
2020 is the most challenging year that
i've ever had to face and i'm sure that
many of you have
found that same challenge both
psychological and
physical challenges and as a community
we're in exactly that same situation
we've had all sorts of challenges
throughout us but in the midst of all
those challenges there are some really
unique opportunities and the one
opportunity we want to talk about today
is the opportunity to reinvent two of
our most well-loved and well-used
community facilities the library and
gore
and the james coming wing facilities
that i'm sure that everybody
has at some point in time used and and
really enjoyed
but both of those facilities have got to
the end of their lives and they need to
be reinvented they need to be reinvented
so that they are going to be useful
for the next 50 years if not more join
us in this journey as we reinvent this
facility into an amazing community space